where's amc right now by the way where
is it amc
stock got to worry about my own position
oh you're up right now tim
how am i up cause you bought at 898. i'm
up
hold the line hold the goddamn line
we're gonna have the ceo of wall street
bets on
unfortunately ceo no what what is he um
so i looked into him
his name's jamie apparently he was
excommunicated from r
wall street bets apparently a lot of
people dm to me that that you were
interacting with that account
so i don't know if he is accepted by
that community or if they'd be mad if we
were talking to you i don't know but we
missed it anyway because the whitney
cummings podcast went long
yeah where i sat down with whitney for
two hours we patched we had some issues
we kind of hashed it out
um you know and i love whitney and want
the best for her
i'm you know and i and i care about her
deeply and that's why i'm leaving the
state
now i love her to death but she's going
to come down and visit we got to get the
[ __ ] out of here man i'm starting to
feel like
i mean we just california feels like the
house after the party you wake up and
there's just cigarettes everywhere and
it smells dank
you know your friend's mother is just
like you want eggs you're like
no get me out of here let's go
let's go get a bacon egg and cheese cup
of coffee
and a pack of lucky's and that is austin
to me
even though they probably don't have i'm
a little endless i'm not excited about
austin i loathe austin i abominate all
truly i mean and i and i mean this
with my heart uh
that's not a city for me you know 40
year old failed musicians
scooping ice cream stoned at 3 p.m
dress like toddlers is never gonna it's
not gonna be for me
just isn't sorry i know everyone loves
it
but maybe i'll grow to love it there's
parts of it i like
i didn't like this and i made it work um
and new york which i love
don't get me started on new york so i
don't love anything that i don't hate
you know all my friends i kind of
there's something about them i really
love and then there's something about
them i don't like
those are a lot of the relationships i
have i like really love them
and then i also there's something about
them like i don't like you know
uh and that's
you know and sometimes it's just as
simple as the fact that they refuse to
[ __ ] me and give me all their money
but i still feel that quality to be
objectionable
in some of my friends um like what i
what i like about ben is that i love ben
he's like my best friend but
also what i don't like about ben is he's
not good at golf and i am really good at
golf
and he's not a good golfer never was
that's what bothers me about him now
obviously that's funny because ben was a
very good girlfriend i don't golf at all
but the reality is ben knows if i put my
mind to it i could be the greatest
golfer in the world
and maybe i'll do that i'll quit comedy
so i could just be the greatest golfer
of all time
and he has to stand on the sidelines and
just
while i walk up 18 in augusta and the
crowd roars my name
they roar my name and i just walk there
and i hold the club up
[Laughter]
and i just have those khakis and that
polo shirt and everybody's just happy
and you said golfers are boring very
boring i i had a guy come over the other
day
we didn't do anything you know but he
was just so boring
he golfs she said golf he's a boring
golfer
he just sat outside and just they
they're nothing
they're literally just they just want to
watch that little ball going to the hall
and they just love jesus and donald
trump and trump yeah
they love jesus and trump and they just
want to watch the ball go into the hall
and i get it because listen they're you
know you got to be good at something
right so
we'll see but so i'm up right now amc
hold the line and we're going you got to
go in heavy
not now it's up buy the dips [ __ ] these
people
[ __ ] elizabeth warren where's gamestop
oh it's
it's doing okay 320. it's doing okay do
i go into gamestop now no
i think you buy a dip i gotta buy the
dip yeah
the unfortunate thing is when it hits
like 400 they halt trading and then it's
like
that's like illegal it has to be that's
illegal
you know what else is illegal killing uh
john f kennedy
[Laughter]
that didn't really stop but it's illegal
they're halting the trading
i mean i just don't get it folks
it's falling now no uh we're going up
right now
we're going out going up ben is now in
the stocks he like thinks he's an
investment
like a financial advisor and he's been
trading stocks secretly for how long
without letting me know
like three weeks yeah and he's not let
me know because he wants to i think he
wants to leave the show
and he wants to create uh an
infrastructure
we have to create an infrastructure and
he wants to
uh make enough money now in the in
capital markets where he just doesn't
have to
do this show anymore because he truly
really hates me
that's the thing about him that none of
you understand is that every day he sits
here and he just
wishes he had the guts to plunge a
kitchen knife into my throat
he's heard me talk more than anyone he
really has think about that
you guys hear me talk an hour a week two
hours a week if you're on the patreon
uh bennett just hears me talk for hours
and
hours and at to a point where it's like
not only i'm sure is it not fun
the grading nature of my voice has to
just it's just
like he drives home his little tesla
and then he's probably just like [ __ ]
that guy
but you're excited about austin because
you're going to see your family stoked
and a lot of your friends live there
yeah i got family outside dallas it's
going to be great yeah it's going to be
great go down there and golf
go down there and retire ben thinks he's
going down to retire he's going to work
how's nokia it's been really going down
today this is the end of the day friday
right
this is the market on friday
we're recording this is going out
saturday
and then we'll we'll see what happens
baby hopefully they get above board here
i hope so too i just want to know if i
should just start dumping money into
other things
on the dip is there there's i can buy
after hours right
no uh with td ameritrade i don't know if
you can
interesting yeah [ __ ] robinhood by the
way get
get my twitter up this is something i
found out
this is gonna blow your mind you want
your mind blown
do you want your mind blown what is that
by the way
what oh yeah i tweeted uh elizabeth
warren okay keep going down
okay oh by the way that guy josh brown
cnbc wears the fake business isn't that
nice
good for him there he goes get go down
you're gonna lose your mind here watch
this this is a fact the ceo of robinhood
is just lane maxwell's son
that's real did you know that no that's
just lane maxwell's son
why is that funny well he's russian
right correct
well his name his name's not gonna be
maxwell
that's legit that's legit that's legit
i'm saying it's legit because i care
about you
you see that i care about you so much
i almost want to start crying that's why
i'm sharing this information with you
because i care about you so much
that i want you to believe this
they do look alike that's how believable
it is i mean
it's so believable because they do look
alike now it's probably not the
it's probably not the case and it kind
of looks like jeffrey and just lane like
do you think that just lane is trading
in prison
do you think he's on the phone with a
broker i want to buy a game stop
i feel so sad here i'm in chair i want
to buy amc i love the movies
i want to get in heavy to gamestop and
nokia
listen i want to go against the rich too
my whole life i've been serving the rich
i want to go against i want to get a
part of a populist revolution
i want about dogecoin tell everyone
about dogecoin ben
so dogecoin's an altcoin um it's a risky
investment because it's not like real
didn't it go up 800 percent it did yeah
i sold early i shouldn't have but elon
musk tweeted about bitcoin today and it
went up
yeah and he put it in his bio get in the
game folks
elon's leading the charge on this whole
thing he really is well because
he you know the one thing about elon
musk is that he's poor
and he understands the struggles of poor
people and that's why
i'm kidding no he's kind of a populist
now right yeah him and chamoth
chamath uh what's this guy yeah yeah
this guy
they're they're kind of leading the
charge with the bitcoin stuff
yeah listen this facebook and robinhood
app are the same they both trick you
into thinking you were the customer but
in fact
you are the product and your data is the
asset
these assets are then sold to their true
customers who pay the money and always
at your expense stop being traded
which i think is like citadel owns all
the data the citadel is like
yeah they own all the data from
robinhood so you're trading on robinhood
and citadel's going what are they
buying how are they buying it you know
so that is the real asset to real
commodity and that's interesting that's
why robinhood is
owned really truly by these big money
players the robinhood guy's a
billionaire too but like the
institutions are
who he has that's where his loyalty is
it is not to his customers it is to the
people that own that app
and get his the information the data
that he sells them right
and then when you understand that you
understand how this whole thing works
and if you have trouble understanding
you just got to go up the line
until somebody's in the woods with a
goat mask because that's really the way
it is
so you just go you go but i don't
understand it doesn't make sense and
then it's like oh
here's a photo of you at jeffrey
epstein's birthday what do you think
about this you go
well i'm concerned about the market
instability
and i'm concerned about so up the line
they just go right into blackmail if
they need to just go in a hardcore
blackmail
but you don't even have to do that
anymore because people are just so
terrified of being ruined financially
being on the road because this this will
die down right because all these hedge
fund guys
the way they talk to they go listen this
is gonna end this will end
and when it does you're ju it's like
your kid and the bully picks on you
but your older brother's there that day
and then the bully is like hey man one
day we're gonna catch you without him
so at the end of the day it's like this
[ __ ] knows he's like hey man
it's gonna end one day you're not gonna
be the folk hero reddit
if that's which you know he didn't
choose that route but like if you go
that route
okay but just realize that one day
we're gonna catch you without your boys
we're gonna catch you without your
avatars
and we're gonna get yeah and that's
that's probably the way
it happens i imagine that's the way it
happens that guy's
threatened he's threatened they bring
him in a room and a guy comes in a room
uh in a goat mask with a cloak and goes
there's two ways we can do this you can
shut down training on these particular
securities
or we can literally at our next seance
roast you on a barbecue spit
in the woods and this guy goes okay
i don't see he's rushing he knows how it
is he knows what they do
they poison yeah he knows he's a russian
they get it they know people have long
memories over there